[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دول الجوار والاصدقاء في الغرب والشرق انا
للسلام والخير والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق
مصالح شعوبنا ويصون حقوق امتنا واننا لن
نسمح منطقتنا ميدان للصراعات ويكفينا طي
صفحه الماضي تذكر سنوات مؤلمه من الصراعات
عاشتها المنطقه وعارتش منها شعوبها وتعثرت
بسبب مسيره التنميه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم حضور فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد لهذه
القمه وصدوق قرار جامعه الدول العربيه
بشان استئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه السوريه
في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
ونامل ان يسهم ذلك في دعم استقرار سوريا
وعوده الامور لطبيعتها واستئناف دورها
الطبيعي في الوطن العربي وما يحقق الخير
لشعبها وما يدعم تطلعاتنا جميعا نحو
المستقبل افضل لمنطقتنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ويطيب لنا ان ننتهز هذه الفرصه بوجود
فخامه الرئيسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ومشاركه هذه
القمه المجدد تاكيد موقف المملكه الداعم
لكل ما يسهم في خفض حده الازمه في
اوكرانيا وعدم تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه
واستعاده المملكه واستعداد المملكه
الاستمرار في بدل الجهود الوساطه بين
روسيا الاتحاديه واوكرانيا ودعم جميع
الجهود الدوليه للراميه الى حل الازمه
سياسيا بما يرسم في تحقيق الامن والسلم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]